the Joe Rogan experience there's a
little controversy this week that
instagrams gonna take the likes away
from yeah I heard about that it's gonna
take the lights away to terms like
viewing two-minute buys you can see how
many likes you got for a post having
please have many views you can see it
all but I can't see how many likes you
got if you put up a picture and your
picture got 40,000 likes
I can never see that Wow so they can
still make their money off it but
everyone else won't come to a contest of
like speculation is that it's going to
drive advertising dollars into giving
money directly to Instagram instead of
people
oh those [ __ ] those fun that's really
with it but if you were a Instagram
right and you had people making sure
tons of money off your platform just by
posting things hey this is my new butt
cream or whatever the [ __ ] you're
selling yeah and they don't even get a
piece of that they got to be like hey
what are we doing we're spending a
million dollars a month and [ __ ]
bandwidth probably way more than that
actually and way more than that they
have videos and [ __ ] till you can upload
videos it's got to be millions in
bandwidth for every month and then I
can't know that I get it so people go
there they'll get to my other ads it's
do they still monetize them but you'll
be able to show like if you if you have
you know a go if you have a screenshot
of your phone do that I also think that
it's gonna daeun sent avise people to
like photos exactly because you don't
see you're making a difference right
who's made more money than those but
doctors because of Instagram like if you
look like the percentage of like uptick
in revenue yeah like but doctors like
guys who just specialize in better
that's Instagram made them they put them
on the map these dudes out there with
but don't going drugs they Robert do
Pato do you know there's a theory that
that I think is true that women are just
hotter these days because they're always
on the verge of being on Instagram so
even to go to the supermarket putting
makeup on they're putting nice nice
clothes on they're always looking their
best because they learn to a friend they
might get uploaded
this is a tough time to be frumpy yeah
you know if you're a gal there's a lot
of competition out there and there's a
lot of lot of these hoes go for it
okay they don't they go for it they're
pulling their panties aside and at 38
percent of their pictures you know I
mean there's a lot a lot of like strong
competition out there now they're
changing the bar
[Applause]